This is the
lowest quality sake with a taste that has lost your physical strength after finishing this
, you can't lie.  Until the end of the day,
let's start cooking Let's make the best sake dish It's just right
I see.
I don't mind if you give it to me
Of course, if the food meets the standards by sunset In other words,
it's absolutely impossible to reach the passing line from now
[music]
Music]
Towards the direction of music] Cheap ingredients information as usual Delicious loser
Yukihira Uranaka was the final of the selection
I don't have anything to worry about
7 minutes.
Oh,
if you
look for it, you'll definitely find it.
It was me who served delicious food haha
[music]